to win elections that's where I selected
Prime Minister Tony Blair welcome to you
who did you vote for
last week I voted labour I said I was
going to and I did although without any
great enthusiasm frankly but I did well
what do you say to people I was the
Campbell who voted for the liver donors
I say I understand why you did what you
did he wouldn't be the only person I I
know who'd voted labour all their lives
that didn't vote labour in this this
election now what should the Labour
Party do because obviously it's vote has
been crushed as tomorrow says it's been
losing votes in both direction yeah it
should stop equivocating basically and
come out to a clear position but and
that position in my view should be in in
favour of going back to the people but
it should do so after we go through a
proper process in Parliament that this
is part of the problem which is that
people people are looking for a
compromise on briggsie because well if
you're a if you're a responsible
politician you're looking at the country
what are these results tell you well you
can argue about the breaks of party
becoming number one but then if you
stack up the votes of the Pro remain
parties it's a bigger percentage vote
than the brags at party and you get so
what these results really tell you is
the country's profoundly divided so what
people look for is a compromise over
brexit unfortunately that's not possible
you can get a compromise over the right
process to reach a final decision I
think even though that will be very
difficult but there is no brexit
compromise because the one compromise
that would make sense
which is a soft brexit in other words
Britain stays in the trading system of
the European Union even if it leaves the
political system that's a compromise
that just doesn't work because those
people who voted for Nigel Faraj and
voted for brexit one out of that trading
system that is integral I mean at that
point and I think you'd probably agree
with this is that we'd be leaving but
we'd still be subject to European Union
laws which they want right and because
of course brexit is based essentially on
a myth which is that we're not in
control of our own laws when we
obviously are for the vast bulk of what
this country needs to do for its future
that the brexit ears have been driven to
focus on the single market and the
customs union as the things that destroy
our sovereignty even though by the way
it was a Conservative Party the first
initiated these
things so it's you're in a situation
therefore that the compromise people
seek over Briggs it which is a soft
brakes that I you stay in a relationship
problem is it comes from a very
well-intentioned place I completely get
why people want to do it but if you're a
Labour Party politician you'll worried
you're hemorrhaging votes to the brexit
party because you've not been clear
about briggsie and you come out with a
soft brexit that the brexit ears say is
a betrayal you're gonna be no better off
in fact you're going to be worse off
because you'll have alienated the people
who want to remain from the Labour Party
but you won't have given those people in
these traditional working-class labour
seats who have voted breaks you weren't
have given them a reason for coming back
you see that's the problem because
suppose labour moves in the direction of
openly backing another referendum it
loses Bolsover it loses Mansfield it
loses all those constituencies it really
loses Gloria DiPietro's constituency
right so that's the challenge so what
would I do if I was yeah right it's to
realize that there isn't a brexit
compromise and you've got to do two
things there's there's one of two ways
of resolving this there's a sensible way
and then there's a not so sensible way I
fear will go in the not so sensible way
and let me come to that in a minute
the sensible ways to do what so far has
not happened in Parliament which is you
lay out the options for people hard
brexit soft brexit No Deal brexit you
explain those options you force
Parliament to come to a decision and
it's at that point that in my view
Parliament will realize the sensible
thing is to decide on a form the brexit
but give the final say to the people
because your hard brexit is going to be
extremely painful economically and your
soft briggs that will be point of what
you're saying effectively is you think
the choice is between effectively and no
deal breaks it and remaining I mean
that's that's really what it comes yes
because otherwise yet if the whole case
of brexit is get out of the single
market and customs union there's no
point in doing it breaks that the people
who advocate Briggs that say isn't a
proper break do you think that's what
mr. Corwin should do now say that the
Labour Party wants a referendum on
basically absolutely or absolutely
laying I think you should do that but I
think it'd be sensible he
we'll advocate a path in Parliament
first that educates both Parliament and
the British people that the reason why
Parliament has been stalling over this
is not because Parliament's a bunch of
nerdy Wells who just wanted to walk the
will of the people it's because there
are different forms of brexit with
hugely different consequences and you
have to choose a form of brexit and
therefore one of the reasons why it's so
important to go back to the people for a
final say is after three years of this
mess and a decision of this magnitude it
makes perfect sense to say look do you
want to tell them again or do you want
to think is this preferable to having a
general election yes a general election
look the Conservatives but what Jeremy
Hunt's saying there is absolutely right
the Conservatives would be I mean look
this is modern politics but they would
be certifiably insane
to do a general election in the shadow
of Greg's head so I think the less
sensible route to a solution which is
what I'm fear will do is you'll have a
new Tory leader this Tory leadership
competition is going to be a competition
in Briggs Atlas who can be more Briggs
it than the other person and I think all
of those Tory leadership candidates
whoever emerges will go back to Europe
they'll try and essentially if you read
what they're saying they're still trying
to to pitch this idea that Europe is
going to allow us access into the market
without abiding by the rules they will
find Europe says no to that and Europe
will not make concessions to a hard-line
Tory leader that they were not prepared
to give - teresa may you'll then have a
situation where no deal is on the table
but here is my prediction there is no
Tory leader that would be crazy enough
to try and tip this country into no deal
brexit without going back to the people
so you don't believe them what they're
saying now and their leadership campaign
I mean I believe that they some like
Boris Johnson perfectly prepared to
advocate no deal but you cannot possibly
argue that the June 2016 referendum is a
mandate for no deal these guys said at
the time if you remember that the deal
was going to be easy they said you know
the Germans will be queuing up to give
us what we wanted so I don't think any
of them because you know if you're a
Tory leader and you really want to own
no deal for the Tory party and one of
the things that
is how the conservative party that when
I was growing up used to be the sort of
common sense party if you like has now
become literally this sort of Farraj is
grouping I mean it's a for the Tories to
put themselves in the position of that
narrow nationalistic viewpoint is an
extraordinary thing for them to do but
if we come down to this referendum which
you're advocating there is a chances in
there that people out of patriotism
national pride say well so be it let's
get rid of you there's a there's a
there's a chance of that how likely do
you think those I don't think it's
likely I think if you mount a proper
campaign and put the arguments in the
proper way you will bust apart the
essence of the brexit case which is that
we're not a sovereign country when we
obviously are you see that's that that's
the problem there you might have mounted
a proper campaign but we haven't had a
proper campaign missus may Jeremy Corbyn
they didn't do interviews they didn't
debate each other they didn't go on the
public stage during this recent election
campaign and frankly in previous
elections I mean that's what that's what
the country lacks isn't it absolutely
it's what it likes and I think if there
is a new campaign you will find that
that it's a much more equal type of
campaign because the arguments of the
Rajas of this well they're gonna be
answered welcome who is the person who
take on Nigel Farage it's not it so I
don't think there's one person that
takes him on as it were but I think that
anybody who gets into this campaign with
the right set of arguments is going to
find you know they can have the argument
in the right way
look if you think of the challenges
faced in this country on the health
service or taxes or public spending
living standards inequality climate you
know any of these challenges breaks it
is not the answer to any of them the
answers are to be found here in this
country but you see the problem is is
that you know Nigel Farage is probably
the most persuasive communicator around
and unless he's taken a head-on he might
he might win the other one well he will
have to be taken head-on but he will be
and who will do it well I think a range
of people who do it but well you know
some names because I'm choosing the
names now cuz I think would be difficult
to invidious
look in the end if you have a fresh
campaign I think it will allow us in the
light of three years of experience to go
back into this argument and by the way
when people say well isn't the risk that
then people will will vote for hard
breaks it or No Deal breaks it I'm
afraid if that is honestly what the
British people want with all the
information they now have after the last
three years we're gonna have to make the
best of it then then you can take the
Kenneth Clarke argument and and he just
doesn't look the problem is referenda
that that our relationship with Europe
is a complicated technical matter should
be handed by the people and we don't
want to go back and ask the people again
look what happened last time would be
his own yeah I get that a hundred
percent that here's the problem ken we
had a referendum now I was I think the
one person who made the speech in the
2015 election saying do not have a
referendum on Europe it's the wrong
issue to try and solve though I mean
he's promised you promised referendums
on the various European treaty I promise
with some had to be persuaded so well
but he of course but no I was for a
referendum if we joined the single
currency I think if you were a
government that proposes a change a huge
change in the status quo I think there
is a case for having a referendum I
think what there is not a case for doing
is having a referendum on the status quo
when you the government actually want to
keep the status quo that's an incredibly
dangerous thing to do because it lands
you in the situation where we we have
been landed in where you as a government
are then forced to deliver something you
profoundly don't believe it what do you
think of mrs. May what are your feelings
for her so I feel very sorry for her on
a personal level and you know I know how
difficult the job is so personally I'm
deeply sympathetic and I wish had
nothing but good luck in the future but
obviously I don't agree I remember other
word she rebuffed yeah I mean you
offered to me with her and taught her
and she didn't want to do that right
well we didn't actually have a
conversation but and I honestly think
she she tried to do the best for the
country but in the end the problem with
this brexit business is that it's
it's a binary choice and this is the
difficulty and I as I said I completely
understand why people think well isn't
there some way we can keep everyone
United and onside with each other
I'm afraid it's such a destiny changing
decision that the answer that is no you
can maybe unite people around a process
for reaching the decision which is why I
think if you did this in the way I
described a proper process which we'd
not had yet in Parliament and then a
decision by the people you might get to
greater unity but you're not gonna find
a compromise on brexit itself and and
you know as I have tried to explain to
her and to others in the end the choices
on breaks it you know one is the suit
and one is a dress and you can have
bespoke versions of both but they're
different you know Boris Johnson you've
come across them as a journalist and
most things is easy someone who is fit
to be Prime Minister and though you
don't agree with his politics
I wouldn't vote for Boris Johnson as
Prime Minister that's pretty obvious you
know I'm not gonna get into fit or not
fit that's a pretty heavy thing to say
about so much has been raised by
candidates like Louis do it yeah but you
know in the end that's a Tory leadership
campaign they can have their leadership
campaign my worry is less about Boris
Johnson than that the position that he
represents and that position is a
position where and this is the
fundamental problem with these breaks at
people they are uniting two groups of
people to get Briggs it who
fundamentally disagree with each other
one group of people like my some of my
former constituents who actually worried
about globalization worried about things
like immigration and want a halt to the
way the world is going the other people
like Boris Johnson are ultra Thatcher
IDEs and they put these two bits of this
coalition together and the real danger
if we if we do break said is that you're
going to get to the situation where if
you tumble out of Europe for example
with the hard Briggs or no deal brexit
Boris Johnson is going to be got one
thing to go in the direction of
deregulation lower taxes smaller state
and the foot soldiers that delivered
brexit are going to be going in
precisely the opposite direction there's
one of the reasons why you know if you
get to another referendum it's gonna be
a very simple argument do you want to
carry on argument what breaks it for
years to come or do you want to switch
out of this complete diversion
from the real challenges of the country
and get back to facing those challenges
and dealing with them if the Tories make
a mess of it breaks it's unresolved and
we have a general election do you think
Jeremy Corbyn would win it I think it
all depends whether it happens in the
shadow of Briggs it it Briggs it's an
issue at the next election the Tories
are at risk if it's not then obviously
they're in a stronger position but at
risk from Jeremy Corbyn as he stands now
well it's a whole other topic but and
look it's no secret I don't agree with
the direction the Labour Party's gone in
under Jeremy Cortland but I think if
brexit is unresolved and you have a
general election then the risk for the
Tories is the risk they ran in 2017 and
then more so and there is for labour the
risk of a Labour is if it doesn't put
forward a set of policies that can
command support in the centre as well as
on the left then it can't get to a
majority and that who said essentially
on Europe I mean that mr. Cole has got
to move on Europe well I think on Europe
he's just got to come to a clear
position I mean the one thing that's the
one thing that is very obvious is that
both party leadership's have made the
same mistake which is to think that it's
possible to sit on the fence on Europe
and appeal to both sides what the
European elections show you is that
isn't possible I mean he celebrates his
70th birthday at the weekend although if
you send him a card or not well I tend
when people get to that stage they
probably don't want reminding that's how
I feel and I'm younger yeah well should
I
man to lead the LED party still I mean
look there's questions about the
leadership but those are for another day
in my view well I mean because I think
the issue today is is the issue today
frankly this breaks it and you know all
the concentration and all the energy has
got to be to sorting out a Labour Party
position that's sensible that can
command as much support as possible that
actually deals argument by argument with
the concerns of those moderate Labour
MPs in brexit voting seats who worry
that if we come to a much more
pro-european position their seats will
be lost I mean do hold out much hope in
Tom Watson I mean often he
the man who did you in as as Prime
Minister to a certain extent yeah but
you know politics moves on and I never
bear grudges in politics I think Tom
Watson shown a lot of leadership in the
last year or so and I I support what
he's trying to do within the Labor Party
which is to give a you know a broad
shelter to those MPs that believe that
Labour wins when it when it wins for a
center-left position and you know this
is a debate you're talking to each other
you and Tom Watson yes of course I mean
I talk to a lot of Labour MPs and you
know I talked to MPs across the
political spectrum actually and and one
of the things that's very very obvious
is that quite apart from the issue it
breaks it there is a large centre ground
in British politics today that's not
represented and you know if the Tory
Party really do go to being a sort of
brexit party in other words they think
the way to defeat Nigel Farage's to
Athan if they really do that and the
Labour Party stays in a far left
position then I've said you know on many
occasions you've got a vast amount of
territory and British politics that's
just open an empty I mean there is
another analysis which is around today
following the results of the European
elections which simply says the old
red-blue politics are finished that
people now identify in different ways
they're more concerned about where they
stand or brexit than they are whether
they support labour the Conservatives
and many people concerned about the
environment all the rest of it you've
talked about open and closed I mean do
you think the Labour Party in the
Conservative Party have outlived their
usefulness I don't I think I put them in
a different way if they if they retreat
to ideological extremes of left and
right I think they will make themselves
irrelevant to the challenges of the
future but I think it's perfectly
possible for either of those parties to
recapture the basis upon which they
111th across Europe yeah it has you're
right and and if you look it's a it's
you know because the lesson of these
European elections is yes you have had a
certain popular surge hello not actually
as much as people think that you've had
a move away from right and you've had a
big move forward I mean actually the big
winners in Europe had been the the
liberals and greens so ya know I do
think I think what it shows you is
people's traditional allegiance you know
when I was growing up there were people
who vote Labour no matter what no people
who vote Tory no matter what it wouldn't
matter who you put up what the position
of the party was they would simply vote
for the party for the tribe I think that
party allegiance has weakened in today's
world I think the sociology of politics
has shifted and therefore I think if the
two main parties go off to the extremes
or they become just the guardians of the
status quo in circumstances where people
want change then you will get new
political groupings formed the point I'm
making to you is that the Tory Party or
the Labour Party it's open to them to go
back to more sensible positions it's
just at the moment they don't show any
signs of doing that in mind and their
meeting today the present European
leaders who should be the next EU
presidents you know I've always taken
the view that you should you should for
the president of the Commission you
should get the most competent person for
the job I don't think it matters I think
I felt very bad doesn't exactly inspire
we you can go through each of these
candidates the important thing is I mean
all of these candidates are people that
those who will make the decision and
after all it's the leaders of sovereign
nations who will make those decisions
all of them will work with all of these
candidates actually I think it's pretty
good range of choice in those candidates
so they should choose the most capable
person for the job that's the sensible
thing Barney a well he's one of the
options deserves about four or five
different candidates and you know he's a
perfectly competent person for the
Commission you've got to have a
competent executive for the leadership
of the council then that's someone I
think who can also speak for Europe and
give some sense things might be
interested in one of those jobs but she
is constantly said not so I think you've
got to assume that she is I just fired
question to you you know what we don't
know the answer to this question but how
do you feel do you think the UK is ever
going to leave the European Union or not
I think but you've got to aim offer the
position I I hold I think it is more
likely now
that we will have another referendum and
more likely that therefore we will vote
to stay in the European Union but I
think we live in a era of unique
unpredictability and there are so many
different variable factors before we
reach that point but I think the only
way you're ever going to bring this
country back together is through a
reasonable process for deciding whether
we really want to leave Europe or we
want to to stay and then hopefully the
emergence of a political coalition and a
government that addressed the true
challenges of the country of which by
the way as I constantly say the
forthcoming technological revolution is
the single biggest challenge we face and
no political party in this country is
yet even addressing it